you know can we actually
i mean i think you're asking me that
question that kant basically was trying
to get at
was can we know the thing in itself can
we know that
can we have like some kind of like
intense
knowing of it it's almost mystical um
and i would say
that that's where religion comes in
okay that's where we talk about religion
um and if i may
also go back to emmanuel kant this idea
that he just before he died just as he
died he was working on
he did this critique of reason where
basically he believed
he he basically um talks about
can we know what's real he basically has
this long you know that question can we
know it's real
and then you know a thousand pages later
no i'll just give you the rundown okay
so okay yeah yeah exactly um then he
does this other
uh critique and okay so he does like
three critiques
then he does this critique of judgment
okay well judgment is this other thing
altogether
and i think that that's what you're
getting at so how do we know things how
can we know things
really intensely and intimately and i
think that he thought that judgment
was the idea that we can actually
um know the thing in itself and he was
working on that
as he died and then he never finished it
hannah arendt
another philosopher of the 20th century
took it up
took up the critique of judgment and
tried to finish it
oh why the word judgment because
judgment think about it
when you see a work of art who judges
that to be
decent okay so there's a there is um
a group of people who come to the
decision that
that's rotten or you know that's pretty
good
you know like um i noticed that you like
to play guitar
well you choose music that i happen to
like too okay
so you and i both have a you know sense
of judgment just a sense
so he said there's a sense that some
people have
why do certain communities have a
similar sense
what what dictates that and so he was
working on that he thought it had
something to do with
the knowledge the intimate knowledge of
the thing in itself um
yeah so another um philosopher that
philosophers actually don't like at all
but religious studies people do is
martin heidegger so martin heidegger
has some great essays one is called what
is a work of art
and again he gets to you know he talks
about van gogh and van gogh's shoes you
know that picture the
the painting van gogh shoes it's really
a
really intense picture it's just shoes
it's you know it's but it's a it's an
amazing painting
of shoes and i think everybody can agree
that's a cool picture of shoes right and
so why
you know the question is why is that a
cool picture of shoes you know what kind
of
knowledge are we accessing to determine
that
indeed that that works right and in fact
we still like it
so basically the the nature of knowledge
and what does it represent
it can operate in the space of that's
detached from reality
or can it ultimately represent reality
i guess that's the is that that's the
space of metaphysics
is that is that yeah so what can we know
is actually called epistemology
epistemology but metaphysics is is
basically
what is the nature of reality right and
those intersect
absolutely yeah a lot of things
intersect in philosophy we just have
fancy names for them
you